App dev, Analytics, Security,
and so much more on This Week
In Cloud, where we bring
you the lowest latency news.
Google Cloud Next
was crazy this year
with lots of announcements,
so let's get started.
First up, the latest
launch is in App dev.
Anthos was launched,
which helps you
span across hybrid or
multi-cloud environments
with your services.
Using Kubernetes through Google
Kubernetes Engine and GKE
On-Prem, you'll
have a standard way
to deploy services with built-in
policy and security automation,
plus unified monitoring.
And to help support automation
across hybrid workloads,
Cloud Run was also
announced, which
enables developers to
run serverless containers
in a fully-managed fashion on
GCP, on GKE, or on premises.
In the world of
databases and analytics,
one of our most
exciting announcements
was BigQuery BI
Engine, which allows
you to do first-class BI in
Data Studio, our dashboarding
and reporting tool.
You can now use a super-fast
in-memory analysis service
for BigQuery to analyze
large and complex data
sets interactively, all with
sub-second query response
time and high concurrency.
Analysts can perform
speed-of-thought data
exploration on their latest
data via Data Studio and Google
Sheets.
Plus, Cloud SQL
just added support
for a new database type--
Managed SQL Server, a
fully-managed service
for SQL Server but with built-in
performance, scalability,
and security so you can
focus on your applications.
On the data management
front, our Data Fusion launch
provides a fully-managed,
code-free data integration
service that helps you
move data and then process
and land that data within GCP.
And we can't forget about
the exciting announcements
in machine learning.
AutoML tables was
launched, which
enables you to
automatically build models
on arbitrary tables of data,
like BigQuery tables or CSV.
Now, data scientists,
analysts, and developers
can automatically
build and deploy
state of the art
machine-learning models
on structured data at a
massively increased speed
and scale.
We've also announced incredible
launches in security.
Our Cloud Security
Command Center
went GA a single
centralized dashboard
that helps security teams gather
data, identify threats, and act
on them before they result
in business damage or loss.
And with event
threat detection, it
can detect suspicious
activity from Stackdriver logs
and then flags them
for remediation.
The threats will be surface in
Cloud Security Command Center.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.